I'm joined in the studio by nanaudsen
and I welcome congratulations you
finished the tournament with the win
tell us more about your game at this
moment I think that there is a very
important decision
yes I mean when she came gave me this
bishop I already felt very satisfied and
I think but I think instead of Knight F3
I should have taken with Bishop
it's more accurate I think and after the
touch castle and E4 and the white must
be yeah a bit better yeah
because I have pairs of Bishops and yeah
but after Knight F3 I gave her all these
ideas with Bishop ace3 because if black
exchanged this dark Square Bishop I
think they are fine
Queen A5 and
kc3 or queen D2 the method Queen A3 and
I think black has no problem here
that's why I decided to keep my bishop
and yeah Bishop but uh
here is suddenly Blake's got this very
good play on the dark squares I don't
know if I played
correctly here or not I don't know but I
was calculating again I was calculus
calculating instead of E4 night night E5
with the idea Knight C4 but uh what I
didn't like here B5 maybe B5 and and uh
Rook I would say I was thinking like
group B1
F6 like Knight C4 B takes C4 B takes C4
and Knight C7 she has because I was
calculate Knight B6 she doesn't turn
Knight B6 because I have
Rook B6 but she has Knight C7 so yeah
but
[Music]
um yeah here I have some weaknesses
were it was more or less balanced
position yes but at some point I was
trying to create something but
I don't know
G4 yeah
um
this Pawn struggage structure is very
strange because I didn't know which
piece to exchange and which to save yeah
which keep and okay later on please
continue I had a chance like later on to
keep like
bishop or to exchange with knights so
yeah here I'm worse
I know because my Pawn structure is
terrible
and yeah I I I don't know somehow I saw
this idea in 1995 Bishop A4 Knight C6
something like this but she was in the
time travel and I I that's why I had the
chance otherwise position is bad
and here yeah here I was thinking to
play Knight C6
um like if she gives me this uh Bishop
B8 then I think okay still worse but
more or less I have drawn chances like
this yes I thought yes
yes and maybe I will exchange this
bishop at night also
and maybe I have some drawing chances
here yes this is balance yeah and
um But Here YouTube
yeah I took only eight I decided to give
this bishop this night here nice friend
I thought
I keep balance but I don't know because
black has big advantage on King side so
at the end this Knight took everything
actually I was very surprised because
you know I missed this please continue
this is worse I know continue
and here after G5 after G5 when I played
Queen F2 I thought I after Queen H3 I
have Rook G5 but I absolutely forgot she
has Rook G8 I think this is the only
move which wins are or is there any
other just even Queen H6 because if you
open the G file
six let's say if I go Queen G2
but somehow yeah after E4
it I mean when I played E4 of C4 E4
no no
yeah I don't know because I got some you
know crucified some thread
to be honest I didn't see how how she
could win immediately I don't know she
played Luke Cage but after Queen C5 here
yeah she went I think Bishop H2 and
after King F2 Rook hf6 that's where I
was yeah correct yeah that's what I was
thinking and here if I maybe yeah
crazy life yes I was concluding his
actually
yes uh queen of no I think I should I
should have shouldn't take this
uh Rook Maybe
I don't know Queen D5 or something where
I don't know something I was calculating
but I don't know this is crazy yes
um so it didn't your opponent and
yourself you were in a time travel yeah
she was in turn trouble that she that's
why she couldn't find this Rook hf6
because after Bishop D6 I think it's
already lost
correct so yes this at the end
everything was crystal clear
um Nana so now the tournament is over so
more you have a free day
are you going on a shopping spree
tomorrow more shoes
I will I think whole day I'll sleep
tomorrow because no energy for shopping
I love shopping when I arrived here
first thing which I've done here was
shopping I called to the organizer and
ask ask him to take me to the shopping
center
but now I'm totally I mean exhausted yes
I think it's important to uh to talk
about how uh well exhausted actually
players are after the end of the
tournament because you used all your
energy the chess tournaments are
actually very long so you're playing the
second tournament in a row yes and I
didn't expect it to would have been such
a tough like two tournaments in a row
Grand Prix in here
if I knew it I think I would have chosen
one tournament only okay how do you
train
physically physically
I train usually at home I train but I
don't know if it helped helped me here
or not because
it was really one of the toughest
tournament in my HS career that I would
say
thank you I know thank you
since uh Nana finishing on a very high
note indeed well